i know what this place is  the timekeepers have built quite the  circus  and i see the clowns are playing their  parts to perfection  big metaphor guy i love it makes you  sound super smart  i am smart i know okay okay  please sign to verify this is everything  you've ever said this is absurd  sign this too  [Music]  we protect the proper flow of time  you picked up the tesseract breaking  reality  i want you to help us fix it  mommy i need your unique low-key  do i get a weapon yeah  you really believe in this loki variant  luckily he believes in himself enough  for the both of us  it is adorable that you think you could  possibly  manipulate me  i'm 10 steps ahead of you  you're not big on trust are you  you can trust me okay i've studied  almost every moment of your entire life  you've literally stabbed people in the  back like 50 times  why never do it again  you